bonsoir felipe mattioni merci d'être
avec nous on entendu le taux d'incidence
un qui a été multiplié par huit en ces
temps derniers jours en catalogne ce qui
a poussé donc le gouvernement à fermer
les discothèques quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à ces derniers
développements est-ce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à cette mauvaise surprise
bonsoir stéphanie de ma rue et bien oui
il y avait effectivement un risque
n'aurait assisté à une nouvelle phase
épidémique puisque d'une part
effectivement les les portes avaient été
largement réouverte plus d'un mois avant
la date qui avait été choisi l'année
dernière c'est à dire que mon art est
ouvert grand les portes fin mai alors
que l'année dernière on les avait
rouverte saint jouin et l'année dernière
et bien le rebond était arrivé deux mois
après c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de se passer cette année le rebond
arrive deux mois après la réouverture
des portes de l'espagne et donc pour
cela ce n'est pas une surprise en cause
quoi philippe emmanueli les festivals
les rassemblements de jeunes qui ont
causé de nombreux kloster on aurait dû
les interdire ne ne pas rouvrir tous
tous ces rassemblements
alors d'abord il faut pas comparer ce
qui est en train de se passer maintenant
avec ce qui s'est passé dans les
précédentes épidémies
c'est radicalement différent c'est
radicalement différent d'abord parce que
effectivement les populations à risque
aujourd'hui si on vacciner et donc les
populations qui se contaminent ce sont
les populations qui ne sont pas à risque
qui sont les jeunes et c'est vrai que ce
variant est très contagieux on le voit
très très bien parce que le l'activité
notre activité a explosé et envoie 90%
qu'ovide et ses 90 % de jeunes entre 20
et 30 ans en revanche il faut quand même
dire que ces jeunes présente très peu de
symptômes
donc oui on a des cas qu'ovide positif
mais ça ne ressemble pas du tout sur le
plan clinique aux symptômes auquel on
avait à faire face aux précédentes aux
précédentes épidémies sur leur
précédente aux précédents cycles
d'épidémie donc vraiment on est dans un
contexte complètement différent
1 et après il faut savoir que ce qui à
vrai
je dirais généré un retour à des
comportements à risque c'est la fin du
port du masque qui a été interprété très
clairement comme le retour total à la
vie normale si on vous suit bien docteur
on aller vacciner d'un côté peut-être
les jeunes de l'autre qui développent
des formes très peu gras va vous suivre
du coc vide
est ce que dans ces conditions ne
doit-on pas laisser tout simplement
faire marcher l'immunité collective et
surtout ne pas re confiné et ne pas
remettre des restrictions écoutez moi je
trouve qu'une certaine hypocrisie et une
certaine
comment dire superficialité du débat
scientifique parce que ce qu'on voit
également aujourd'hui ce sont des gens
qui sont vaccinés qui viennent faire
leur test pour reprendre l'avion et qui
sont positifs alors évidemment ils sont
pas malades
évidemment ils sont en quelque sorte
porteurs sains mais les vaccinés
contribue également à la diffusion de
virus simplement effectivement ils ne
feront jamais de formes graves et ils
sont protégés contre la maladie
donc c'est vrai qu'entre un jeune qui de
toute façon n'est pas à risque et
contribua à propager l'épidémie et un
vaccinés qui lui aussi ne sera pas
malade et mais contribue potentiellement
également à la diffusion de la maladie
on voit pas vraiment la différence et
c'est vrai que on n'insiste pas assez
sur cette question à mon avis en faisant
simplement la part des vaccinés et des
non vaccinés ça veut dire que ce débat
qu'on a aujourd'hui en france à
d'exhorter la pression devient un petit
peu lourdes 1
exhorté la population à se faire
vacciner compris les jeunes il est un
peu vain ce débat finalement selon vous
c'est normal que ce débat ait lieu mais
il faut que ce débat ait lieu dans des
conditions d'honnêteté scientifique et
comme médecin si vous voulez moi ce qui
me choque c'est que la première démarche
d'un médecin fasse si vous voulez au
discours d'un patient ou la prise de
position de quelqu'un c'est d'essayer de
comprendre et je pense qu'on devrait
s'interroger par exemple sur les raisons
qui poussent un pourcentage élevé des
professionnels de santé à ne pas
vacciner
il faudrait les interroger et leur dire
pourquoi vous ne voulez pas vacciner au
lieu de ça e
finalement on tient un discours qui est
de dire les bons ce sont les vacciner
les méchants c'est ce qu'ils ne veulent
pas sac signer mais on sait que la
france a connu un certain nombre de
scandales sanitaires
il ya eu sans contaminer il ya une
médiator on sait donc que sur un certain
nombre de deux comment dire de mesures
sanitaires à grande échelle
il y a eu des accidents sanitaires et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'une partie de la
population des personnels de soins ont
en mémoire ces accidents sanitaires et
redoute alors que ce soient fondées ou
pas il faut en discuter mais on là
encore il faut une honnêteté
scientifiques redoutent éventuellement
la perspective d'un nouvel accident
sanitaires aujourd'hui voilà nous sommes
à la veille de l'été on va déjà l'été
d'ailleurs ça se voit pas trop à paris
dogon de mon erreur vous craignez vous
cet afflux
massive de touristes en espagne où vous
la voyez plutôt d'un oeil bienveillant
n'ont pas écouté je pense que je pense
que les jeux sont faits c'est à dire que
maintenant le variant delta est en train
de déferler
on retrouve exactement le même scénario
que l'année dernière donc les
contaminations vont se concentrer sur
l'espagne qui est vraiment un pays de
destination majeure de toute l'europe et
donc tout ça va faire émerger
vraisemblablement une vraie vague est
effectivement peut-être qu'on aura des
surprises au mois d'août puisque là
encore comme je vous le disais on a ré
ouvert grand les portes avec un mois
d'avancé sur l'année dernière merci
beaucoup philippa emmanueli d'avoir été
avec nous un médecin libéral exerçant
barcelone merci à vous